I would have done probably four years in
prison for supervising sales reps
talking about our medical devices in a
way that didn't harm any patient howard
root is the CEO and founder of the
medical device company vascular
solutions which develops life-saving
medical technologies such as freeze dry
blood plasma to help wounded soldiers on
the battlefield and catheters that make
heart surgery safer and easier for
doctors but five years ago the Food and
Drug Administration filed a criminal
lawsuit against vascular solutions that
might have sent rout to prison for four
years while tearing apart the company he
spent decades building till we get this
top medical device companies aren't
gonna be started because no one's gonna
be crazy enough to do what I did 20
years ago today with this kind of
culture of prosecution against medical
device companies the dispute that almost
destroyed vascular solutions and landed
this 55 year old executive behind bars
involves the product they call the Vera
lace kit it uses lasers to treat
varicose veins which are not only a
cosmetic issue but also a health problem
that can lead to serious blood clotting
the agency accused root and his company
of selling medical devices without FDA
approval and then conspiring to hide
that fact we're in at litigious industry
so we get subpoenas once in a while but
this was a different subpoena because it
was a federal Department of Justice
subpoena and it was criminal
in 2010 the FDA approved the product for
use on veins near the surface of the
skin but not for veins that appear deep
under the flesh it's not that the agency
found evidence that the Vera lace kit
poses a significant danger when used in
this way it's just the agency didn't
specifically approve the device for this
purpose basically if they have
government's allegation is they're
making claims for which they've not
sought approval or clearance mark Duval
is an attorney who specializes in FDA
medical device compliance if the
government differs with you on the way
you're interpreting your labeling then
have a conversation with the company
maybe at worst write them a warning
letter but you don't indict them and
that's what was it at stake here in the
Howard brood vascular solutions case the
company applied for permission to market
the device for treating the short veins
that connect veins on the surface to
veins buried deep under the
skin these short veins are called
perforators but the application was
denied the FDA claims that vascular
solutions went ahead and marketed it for
this perforator vein use anyway even
developing a special attachment for the
vera lace kit specifically designed for
this purpose so the whole trial was on
this gray hub which we called the short
kit which was just a different version
of this other a standard 12 centimeter
kit so the government claimed that while
we could sell the red hub one that when
we sold the gray hub one that was
considered to be a crime but the FDA's
allegations regarding the grey hub tip
were false
in fact both the red hub and the gray
hub applicators can treat varicose veins
near the surface of the skin it's just
that many doctors chose to use the grey
tip to treat perforator veins as well
doctors didn't need the company's
permission to use the valets kit in this
way using medical devices in ways that
aren't specifically sanctioned by the
FDA which is known as off-label use is a
common and accepted practice government
doesn't progress medical practitioners
in the practice of medicine from doing
that they encourage it they know that
that's the way medicine gets advanced
you could not have cardiology procedures
on children unless you did off-label use
of medical devices because none of our
products are approved for the use on
patients under the age of 18 and
off-label use is recognized as being
legal necessary life-saving but
off-label promotion the government says
that's a crime the FDA charged the
company's sales team with encouraging
doctors to use the various kit for
off-label purposes a key piece of
evidence internal training materials in
which the FDA claimed company trainers
instructed salespeople to market the
product for use on the unapproved
perforator veins in fact these internal
presentations demonstrated no such thing
the presentations referred to doctors
using the device to treat short veins
but short veins are also found near the
surface of the skin and the company did
have FDA approval to market the device
for use near the surface of the skin
perforator veins are short short
saphenous vein is short there's a lot of
short segments and it's not a code word
for something illegal it's just a
description of a length of a vein that
you would treat with our prod
the government flagged an email route
forwarded to the entire Salesforce from
an employee bragging about selling the
kit to a doctor who mentioned that he
planned to use the device to treat
perforator veins noting that this would
alleviate the problem tenfold but
there's no evidence the salesperson was
pushing the doctor to use the device in
this way when they failed to find hard
evidence and internal company documents
US attorneys badgered employees at a
grand jury proceeding hoping to shape
their testimony into something usable I
quickly realized that the US government
is this monster of a thing that they
have all the power and all the money and
all the control and I felt very much
like a pawn with them the government
came back and not only asked for
clarification but stated that if I
didn't clarify it to what they wanted it
to say then certain things would happen
to me I couldn't lose my career I could
be charged and have to do jail time they
want you to sign this document
clarifying your testimony and I remember
reading the document and that's not what
I said and that's not what I intended to
say they wanted me to say I do not deny
that there was a conspiracy at the
company there was a document at one
point that I saw and there were four
current employees listed on there that
the government felt that these employees
had not been cooperative during the
process and were not probably a good
representation of what a company should
have especially in an officer level and
that those people should be terminated
and my name was on that list so they
tell the employees look we're getting
close to settling with the company and
when we settle with the company we're
gonna demand that they fire whoever
doesn't testify the way we want them to
testify so if you get on the right side
before the company settles you're good
if you're on the wrong side the company
will throw you under the bus and your
career will be over at this point the
Department of Justice was pouring time
and resources into destroying an
established medical device company and
fighting to put a well-regarded
executive behind bars
why because vascular solutions allegedly
encourage doctors to use a product in a
way that although it was benefiting
patients the agency hadn't okayed yet
of course that's not the whole story
this whole matter started as most of
these do with a whistleblower
so a disgruntled former employee decides
that he wants to start a complaint and
the system is set up so that the
whistleblower gets 20% of whatever the
government might recover from us in
pursuing his claim the Department of
Justice brags about its return on
investment for the dollar span they
claim that for every dollar they spend
and prosecutorial efforts they're
bringing $8 to the coffers vascular
solutions decided to settle the civil
suit for a little more than half a
million dollars a fraction of what it
would have cost the company to battle it
out in court although the government was
also willing to settle the criminal suit
root refused and insisted on going to
trial even though doing so meant risking
jail time we were fine if we had to pay
money we were fine if we had to do
compliance but we weren't going to take
employees who had done nothing wrong and
fire them and get them excluded from
anywhere in health care for their career
just to get out of this problem he
definitely could have gone to prison it
was risky to not settle the government's
case collapsed in the courtroom witness
after witness failed to back the
government side of the story the final
blow to the FDA's case came when an
expert witness called by the government
said that using the Verrill a skit on
perforator veins might not even qualify
as off-label use in some instances
undermining the entire premise of the
case one of the key governmental
witnesses basically testified on behalf
of the defense the defense rested
without calling a single witness from
its roster after five years and 25
million dollars in legal fees Howard
root walked free and vascular solutions
was in the clear with a not guilty
verdict the fight changed the way the
entire industry thinks about off-label
use and free speech the government by
acquiescing to a jury instruction agreed
that off-label promotion was not
necessarily illegal if it was wholly
truthful in improper context was her
shattering to the industry the evening
following his big win in court route
received a surprising email from one of
the jurors that said in all my life I've
never feared the government what the
federal government did to you your
company and your employ
is nothing short of criminal people say
you fear a jury
I didn't fear this jury I feared the
judge I really feared the prosecutors
but the jurors are the ones who really
know what's going on and they're the
ones who have justice in their hearts my
experience changed the way that I felt
about how the government is supposed to
protect the innocent and bring down the
bad guys bring down the people who are
truly doing criminal acts after watching
what I saw you know go on with the
prosecutors and how this played out and
how the information was manipulated I
don't think I could go into a courtroom
again and actually believe that the
government was telling the truth I will
never look at the US government the same
again route still worries about the
effect of overzealous regulation and
prosecution on medical innovation and
the health and lives of millions of
Americans what happens to medical device
companies affects the startups and we're
now bigger than the startups we're
substantial we're profitable and we can
continue to grow as long as we want to
but it's a sick feeling when you see not
as much development as it was 20 years
ago today because the government is
punishing people who are trying to start
new companies